hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ihr seht ja schon an der
überschrift heute geht es um die cache
bolt in wien die war anfang september
und ich war da mit murat und meinem
gesamten team für drei tage in wien
wobei morath dorstadt gab es länger
ich war einen tag ich musste den
bulgarischen lkw-fahrer einweisen genau
dem motto k und heute möchte ich einfach
so ein paar eindrücke zeigen und eben
ein bisschen erzählen wie es denn dort
war also ich hatte mir fest vorgenommen
dass sie auf die messe ag und ich hab's
dann wirklich auch geschafft und es ist
auch alles gut gelaufen aber ich muss
jetzt im nachhinein sagen es war doch
ziemlich anstrengend vor allem für mich
also als schwangere data drei tage auf
der messe zu sein und ich persönlich
habe jetzt nicht so viel von wien sehen
können weil ich einfach nur auf der
messe war und ansonsten wollte ich halt
so viel laufen und konnte auch natürlich
zu einem rückenschmerzen hatte aber
trotzdem war es sehr schön und ich würde
sagen wir gucken jetzt einfach ein
bisschen rein oder wir haben wir zeigen
euch ein paar eindrücke
hallo
also wie ihr gesehen habt war es
ziemlich voll an unserem stand und ich
bin sowieso jedes mal beeindruckt wie
viele leute darüber vorbeikommen und ich
habe am ersten tag noch relativ viel
gekocht und gebacken
am zweiten tag wurzelt wiesel weniger
weil es für mich zu anstrengend war und
außerdem wurde ich dann halt immer
gefragt sind können wir mal fotos machen
wir können wir fotos machen
also habe ich mich dahin gesetzt habt
ihr autogramme gemacht und die fotos
gemacht und der murat hat sich daneben
um den rest gekümmert hat aber wirklich
gut gemacht ich habe mich gekocht ich
habe bin ich hab die leute nur solange
zugelassen noch gelacht haben
wie soll ich gemacht nein wirklich ich
habe einen nur getränke verteilt
ja stimmt murat gab es getränke und
sonstwas so ist es mir wichtig wenn man
mit mit eltern auf und auf der messe
geht und mit kleinen kindern das wasser
meistens vier euro 50 gedacht kommen ich
sage einmal getränke alles geht
erfahrung wissen also lustig drauflos
sieben österreicher also ich fand es
auch richtig toll vor allen dingen woher
die leute alle kabel natürlich
überwiegend aus wien und aus österreich
aber ich hatte sogar besucher aus
deutschland die dann extra angereist
sind weil sie wussten dass ich jetzt zum
beispiel nicht mehr auf die messe in
hannover ag und die mich dann eben
unbedingt noch sehen wollten
und ich hatte sogar zuschauer von ganz
weit weg ich glaube die den weitesten
weg hatten kamen aus schweden dänemark
ich glaube schweden ich weiß es ist
alles ikea von dem fernseher ob sie kam
aus schweden glaube ich reden
das war toll und es waren auch besucher
von der letzten messe in friedrichshafen
statt und es zeigt uns dass es euch
einfach bei uns sehr gut gefallen hat
oder sehr gut geschmeckt hat
wahrscheinlich drei tage ist schon
heftig der zuschauer will ich dann alle
drei tage kommt ja das hatten wir auch
dann musste ich natürlich drei tage lang
immer neue mieter finden für das was
dann halt heftig weil das immer so er
fragt dann immer wenn wir vorhin schon
mal da melden sich ein paar
man sagt ja okay da mache ich die
gleichen geht's einfach machen das ist
eigentlich auch schon sein witz und zwar
mit mich von jung bis alt wieder besser
als alte mann keine da ist man
richtig jede altersklasse vertreten
und dann gab es da wieder die
wettbewerber haben wir da ganz viele
tolle torten gesehen und der murat hat
die auch alle aufgenommen ein bisschen
kommentiert ja aber es war ich muss
sagen das war viel zu kurz also jede
tochter viel zeit eigentlich verdient
gehabt aber du kannst einfach es war so
viel torte kunst nicht alle aufnehmen
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer ich
finde es da morath aus der cape bird in
wien
und bevor jetzt die ganzen zuschauer
einkommen hat mir gedacht film ich euch
mal die torten oder besser gesagt der
frankfurt und ich erklärte trocken
was heißt ich erkläre euch ich solle
einfach weil ich weiß nicht was es hier
geht einfach ist einfach ganz ganz
geniale tonnen und jetzt fängt der frank
grad an zu filmen
franck geht man auf die torten fangen
wir an ich weiß nicht wie der typ heißt
keine ahnung
zieht aber richtig gewaltig aus dann
hier demokrat weiter frank du kannst
ruhig mal filmen das ist eine richtig
tolle arbeit
das ist ich komme gerade vor wie so ein
fernsehreporter jawohl und rahn schießen
rahn schießt tor
das ist jetzt wieder eine torte aus der
tasche eine tasche und guckt raus ich
finde auch die augen sehr sehr voll
diesen so glänzende augen hier oben
richtig schön gemacht und vor allem auch
diese falten von der tasche richtig toll
klasse hier ein löwen der aus dem wasser
schaut und tiger tschuldigung für mich
eine katze auf jeden fall ist ist ein
tiger ein weißer tiger jetzt nur bei der
kategorie hochzeit hatten wir machen
jetzt schnell darauf durchlaufe es
wirklich wahnsinnig viel torten sind gar
nicht mehr groß das gefällt mir richtig
farben gefallen mir richtig toll
richtig schön gearbeitet also die alle
torten sind irgendwie gigantisch dessen
jetzt will ich die hochzeitstorten
vielleicht könnt ihr euch ein paar
inspirationen holen was es alles gibt
und jetzt das ist eine ganz ganz tolle
torte ich weiß nicht wie lange die dame
hier gebraucht hat vision wochen lang
wirklich klasse wow das ist richtig toll
aussieht wird nicht richtig toll aus ok
jetzt schon beim kinderwettbewerb es
nicht hoffen für von kindern bis 14
jahren deshalb will ich die kinder
gemacht und was wirklich wahnsinn
schade vielleicht macht nächste mal die
samira mit hier haben auch ein paar
bilder von dem von der damen ist es
richtig toll wie sie die nie die torte
macht gerade diese torte hier richtig
süß richtig toll finde ich klasse so was
wenn kids machen und dieser kürbis
erinnert mich irgendwie total an sally
service wo sie mal gemacht hat mit
sicherheit hier sehe ich auch ein
ausrollen stab von der sally also
richtig cool richtig toll gemacht
jetzt sind die kategorie festtags toppen
da machen jetzt auch einen schnellen
durchgang normalerweise jede torte
verlieren ihres länger gefilmt zu werden
das video darf aber nicht zu lange
dauern
hier haben wir zb ostern das ist mamas
festakt hatte das ist zensiert was
drüber war das ist mal richtig toll
diese jetzt ist unscheinbar aus aber mal
richtig drauf schaut ich kenne dieses
muster und woher ich kann auch diesen
künstler genau jetzt habe ich das ist
eine von gustav klimt und gustav klimt
erkennt mich immer an einer heizung
bestanden bisschen still so ein bisschen
mal stil ist ein berühmter maler also
richtig toll und hier
ich würd ich bin zu wissen wie das
gemacht hat das ist sowieso ich würde
dann hin fassen ich darf aber nicht na
ja und hier wieder so eine schwarze
tasche mit weißer schrift ist es
momentan richtig ihn auch die macarons
den cupcakes die lollis und das war's
jetzt ich hoffe ich habe jetzt mal im
schnelldurchgang alles gezeigt es sind
noch ein paar mehr torten aber ich
konnte nicht alle aufnehmen
und jetzt gehen wir mal auf die messe
und schauen was die so machen
du bist die sophia sofia so wie du bist
aus österreich okay du bist heute
dagegen okay
und natürlich wegen mir wegen mord oder
sie ist am meisten
was gefällt dir am meisten was gefällt
an den coolen videos am meisten
lena du bist heute verkehr bei der sich
auf dem stand auf die kinder gekommen
wegen der sally die zuschauer der
kurpark wie das macht und was gefällt
dir am meisten auf dieser liste
guckst du auf dieses jahr
mama
sli ja sehr gerne wir sind sehr große
fans an irgendwas sagen ich finde sie
einfach toll ja wie sie das alles macht
sie macht es aussieht aus dem herzen
heraus man sieht die leidenschaft
dahinter
und das finde ich einfach toll sie soll
so weiter bleiben wie sie ist
was machst du hier übrigens alida am
besten dieser kleine dicke da der motor
ist so ein volk das ist die katharina
aus wiens sie wollten uns einig wien
zeigen leider ging es nicht weil die
sally sich nicht wohl fühlt man sieht
mich nicht wieder okay katharina du bist
jetzt da natürlich wer kate world auch
wissen dass sally ich frage jetzt mal
gerne zuschauer was gefällt dir das sie
am besten am es ist alles sehr genau
erklärt also man kann den schritten
wirklich sehr gut folgen natürlich ist
auch die videos wegen mir habe ich recht
natürlich natürlich
ich habe mir gedacht vielleicht auch mal
einen großen schild aus österreich aus
österreich es ist also sie nicht aus
österreich aber sie ist in österreich
verkauft sprang greifen lassen das haben
wir erstklassig drücken
also ich hab hier ist suzuki kriegs
wahnsinn oder vielen vielen dank katrina
das uns besucher aus vielen dank du bist
die julia julia du kommst woher aus
österreich julia du bist hier gewesen
wegen der cdu denkbar
guckst du die wir ja warum weil ich
selber gerne parker und die wird sehr
interessant sind wollte das schon immer
sagen also die gelegenheit die sally
schaut es an möchte ich sagen dass ich
sehr dafür bewundere führer wie das ich
würde mich das niemals getan natürlich
julia bisdorf ich mir da wegen mord habe
ich recht sicher okay ja vielen dank
ich darf den preis best of show
übergeben und zwar bedanke ich mich noch
mal bei allen die mitgemacht haben
ich denke alle taten waren wunderschön
und ich bin froh dass ich sie nicht
bewerten eine ganz schwierige aufgabe
thorsten haupt und die dürfen wir jetzt
hier übergeben wurde von kent und
gesponsert und dafür bedanke ich mich
auch nochmal ganz herzlich und schützen
von juni
am ende waren die drei tage eigentlich
ziemlich schnell vorbei und ich bin
immer ziemlich traurig wenn dann
sonntagabends der messestand abgebaut
wird um alles wieder abgehängt wird und
dann ist nicht mehr schön pink sondern
alles wieder schön
er hat sich dann alles leer und dann
sind keine zuschauer weiter und dann ich
mal wieder ganz alleine jeder muss
wieder nach hause fahren
aber natürlich mal dann auch ganz froh
mal wieder nach hause zu fahren denn es
ist wirklich anstrengend so schlimm und
wir waren war ja nicht zu zweit sondern
wir hatten ja unser ganzes team dabei
und insgesamt waren wir ich glaube 17
personen 17 personen personen hallo also
dass das glaubt magath
und wer live mit dabei war hat zum
beispiel auch gesehen dass der murat zum
beispiel dieses video gar nicht gefilmt
hat in der motorrad-wm stand da war
unser zweiter kameramann mit dabei unser
fotograf mit dabei unser sally shop team
war mit dabei und wir haben schon gesagt
dass wir unser team mal vorstellen
wollen
und das haben wir jetzt in unserem buch
gemacht was gerade noch im druck ist und
was bald erhältlich ist unser erstes
kochbuch
da freue ich mich drauf ich mich auch ja
und da geht es hinten drin eben mein
ganzes team da stelle ich das vor und
ich denke dass das interessiert euch was
recht ganz nah und sonst ansonsten habe
ich ja gesagt letztes mal schauen bitte
bringt mir keine geschenke mit natürlich
kann man wieder zuschauer mit geschenken
aber mit so viel weil viele haben gesagt
ich darf dir nichts mitbringen also
bringe ich dir nichts mit und da bedanke
ich mich ganz herzlich dass ihr mir nix
acht habt es für mich dann eben ja ich
habe dann immer dass ich bekommen was
ich ganz schön finden sind immer die
bilder von den kindern ja und ja extra
die woodwing dass es im video zeigt
vielen vielen dank an all das ist für
dich gewesen
richtig schön und sally hat sie schon
geschrieben ich weiß gar nicht mehr für
ihr vieh als sie war
aber ich schätze also 34 34 denke ich
auch dass woanders schrift und richtig
schön
ja und dann habe ich noch ein paar
andere sachen bekommen möchte ich jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht alle zeigen weil
ich hab's ja alles schon eingeräumt
oder sie sind schon aufgegessen von
murat aber weil ich habe die post hat
niemand genäht was ist das bitte sich
einlässt und fußsack acht gotisches süß
für babys das hat er selber genäht
von hartmut punkt at richtig schön da
war auch glaube ich schwangerschafts
buch dabei also für die geburt das habe
ich mir dann auch in den pausen immer
mal wieder durch gelesen ja das problem
ist auch was ich noch sagen wollte wenn
ihr was zu essen bringt ihr kennt mich
aber ich kenne euch nicht und dann ist
das halt immer ich kann er von fremden
da nichts annehmen und dann sagen okay
ich es ist alles
also das ist dann immer vor allem
wintern für die samira ist
ich sage ja dass amira el mhassani haben
nichts von fremden an und ist sowieso
dann auch gar nicht und es dann halt
immer so ein problem also ich persönlich
es dann halt net ich glaube ich mich pro
jahr
deswegen bringt bitte einfach gar nichts
mit kommt einfach vorbei und ja das
finde ich ja schon schön genug
was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen was ich
dieses jahr eben auch keine messe mehr
weil es kann aber mir jetzt jeden moment
soweit sein
und ich merke schon ich bin immer noch
außer puste und ich bin auch sam hüther
im moment und die hannover messe fällt
natürlich für uns dieses jahr aus aber
ihr könnt ihr trotzdem hin gehen das ist
wie sehen diese woche ist sie auch
stimmen
diese woche dieses in hannover es ist
die kreativ müsse also nicht nur die
kate ist da so kreativ müssen auch und
dass ich mir leider nicht vertreten aber
wie gesagt geh trotzdem hin
ist bestimmt trotzdem wird ganz tolle
messe wir sind nächstes jahr mit dabei
und wir haben uns auch vorgenommen
nächstes jahr so eine kleine messe tour
zu machen oder eine große ich weiß es
nicht
wird sie nämlich von ganz vielen messen
schon angefragt worden ob wir nicht auch
dahin kommen wollen und wir suchen uns
das dann einfach ausmachen so ein
messeplan und dann wisst ihr einfach
auch wo wir hingehen genau jetzt haben
sie orten genau in deutschland mit genau
das wenn ich nur 4 termine haben sondern
einfach ein paar mehr mit werde
und wenn ihr dann der messe habt die ihr
ganz toll findet können da und sie
einfach mal schreiben und dann können
wir uns mal angucken und eben überlegen
und war daraufhin gehen also was man
nachfragen österreich ich habe wieder
kaputtgemacht bauen heute noch auf monat
später bei uns auch auf meinem nach cool
war echt schön also wenig echt eine
tolle stadt habe ich nichts der
unbedingt wieder hin
nächstes jahr auch länger ich finde
sommer also immer 45 tage vor der messe
in die stadt noch ein bisschen kennen
außer nur das hotel und messehotel messe
das war ja das war bei uns wirklich
messehotel gesehen einmal nur in der
stadt und richtig schön so richtig
wienerisch oder österreichischer haben
eigentlich gegessen müssen wir ehrlich
sagen er war grauenhaft hingeht
das ist so als studiomusiker gleicher
lena genau so schlau also die türkei zum
essengehen pizza calzone genau das
nächste fährt jetzt ruhe ich mich doch
ein bisserl aus die kleine maus kommt ja
bald und nachts kann ich nicht mehr so
gut schlafen zwingt sich heute auch
somit aus wahrscheinlich auf einer
kollision am freitag kommt kein video
genau am sonntag kommt dann wieder eins
genau war ich hab schwangerschaft demenz
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was wir
vorbereitet haben für sonntag klar
wieder ein bug video nächsten wochen
jetzt kommen erst mal nur zwei videos in
der woche und wenn ihr wollt kann ich
gerne wieder ein schwangerschaftsabbruch
schwanger bin
ich habe schon gesagt die ausstattung
und so weiter zeige ich euch noch da bin
ich aber ehrlich sagt noch ein bisserl
am vorbereiten als ich habe es bisher
geschafft meine klinik tasche zu packen
und die wickeltasche zu packen und murat
wird heute bestimmt das stuben bett
aufbauen was ist ein stuben wird das
bett was ich an meinem bett stelle
carrasso das baby tritt ein
beistelltisch okay aber noch von samira
habe aus dem keller gekramt
ja auf jeden fall freue mich wieder aufs
nächste mal schön dass er eingeschaltet
habt und vielen dank noch mal an alle
besucher war wirklich sehr schön und
nächstes jahr
ich glaube die nächste messe ganz
günstig auf die nächste messe schon
februar in hamburg gehört in hamburg
dies bedingt februar die cia sein genau
ich freue mich schon alles was macht's
gut
da stelle ich das so hoch eingestellt
und ich bin müde und jetzt blendet mich
dass die ganz ohne sonnenbrille hätte
ich vielleicht machen soll